who turned to that murder mystery that
has gripped Canada it did seem like you
were watching a work of fiction
not reality tonight the mystery
deepening behind the double homicide of
one of the world's richest couples but
of course truth is often much stranger
than fiction as I learned as I went on
with the reporting their murder has
shaken the political establishment with
many wondering who could have wanted to
see them dead and why this was just a
seismic event in the history of Canadian
business and Canadian news now police
want to know who would want them dead we
are now well over a year after their
deaths and they remain completely
unsolved
it's quite a McCobb story in terms of
how there ain't honey Sherman were
discovered they were last seen both of
them on December 13th in 2017 they were
trying to sell their home and so their
real estate agent was holding viewings
for prospective buyers and the agent had
a couple touring the home who were being
shown around the kitchen the bedrooms
and they were shown the indoor pool if
you can imagine a line of people there
was one real-estate agent followed by
this couple as well as another agent
that the agent representing the couple
comes into the pool area and sees this
really gruesome tableau a Barry and
honey Sherman suspended from a metal
railing that surrounded one end of the
pool with leather belts holding them up
by the neck she was kind of slumped on
her side a little bit he was more
upright there was then a 911 call and
the police were on the scene very soon
afterward now the billionaire founder of
Canada's largest drugs for Barry Sherman
and his wife honey have been found dead
at their home in Toronto police describe
the deaths as suspicious but say they
were not being treated as murder but
we've discovered two bodies of people
inside a home here the circumstances of
their death appear suspicious homicide
detectives are leading the investigation
but there's still no indication from
police that the deaths are homicides
over the next 24 hours you began to see
anonymously sourced stories in some of
the Toronto papers to the effect that
the police were treating this as a
murder-suicide committed by Barry
Sherman
the Sherman's adult children put out a
statement saying that this was
completely inconsistent with the
character of their parents and they also
put together their own investigative
team and they actually did a second
autopsy which is remarkable they found
things that they believed indicated this
could not have been a murder-suicide
narrow markings on Barry Sherman's
wrists the scene was for lack of a
better word quite cleaned the way in
which the the murder scene seemed to
have been staged and then in late
January the police hold a press
conference we believe now through the
six weeks of work review we have
sufficient evidence to describe this as
a double homicide investigation and that
both honey and Barry Sherman were in
fact targeted we are not police
detectives we do not have access to the
corpus of evidence we are not going to
solve the crime so my goal was create
the richest portrait possible of this
very unusual person and and how he came
to this very unusual end as head of
Apotex the largest pharmaceutical
company in Canada Barry's net worth was
estimated at over four billion dollars
at the time of his death
Barry Sherman was a science guy he had a
PhD in physics at MIT but he had become
an expert in generics and in drugs the
generics business is a very tough one it
is zero-sum in the strictest sense of
the term that means that if you are
selling a branded drug you have had a
significant amount of your profit wiped
out and he was very tough in doing
that's very uncompromising when you
speak to people in the branded
pharmaceutical industry they sometimes
refer to very Sherman and unprintable
terms it has been said though there may
be some exaggeration in the numbers that
he would sometimes be involved in as
many as a hundred lawsuits at any one
time he was a guy who did not like to be
crossed and if someone did betray him or
did something that he felt was improper
or disloyal he would sue he was a tough
guy
definitely someone who
did not have a lot of friends beyond his
inner circle Mary Sherman did face
multiple lawsuits among them a
decade-long bat with a group of cousins
who felt cut out of the Sherman business
these murders had sort of a Murder on
the Orient Express quality to them there
was a long list of theories out there
someone who everyone looked at very
quickly was Barry Sherman's cousin
Carrie winter the son of Lewis winter
the founder of empire laboratories the
company where Barry worked as a student
and later ended up owning and Cary and
his siblings have been engaged in a
legal battle alleging that he owes them
20 percent of Apotex that they were they
were done out of their inheritance he
cared about one thing money making lots
of it and not caring who he destroyed
who he stepped on that is a very bitter
legal battle and it's one where Cary has
expressed publicly and otherwise a lot
of anger said some things that certainly
did not make him less of a suspect I
probably had reasons to lash out to to
do the dirty deed but here he is over a
year later walking free and unarrested
so I think it's safe to say that he had
nothing to do with this police say they
are still talking to neighbors witnesses
family members business associates
anyone who knew anything about the
Sherman's lives or even their last hours
one of the things I was astounded by
when I started reporting this story and
it's something that I really had no
inkling of
was the the extent of some of Barry
Sherman's entanglements with really
inadvisable financial deals businesses
and this put him into bed financially
with a lot of people who really most
high-level pharmaceutical executives
would never have anything to do with
Kevin Trudeau now in jail another
convicted fraudster called Shaun
Ruttenberg convinced Barry Sherman to
invest in a online trivia app the
introduction in that case was made by
someone called Myron Gottlieb they were
caught Leoben Ruttenberg had actually
met in jail and the most dramatic of
these involvement so over the years was
someone named Frank D'Angelo he is
something of a b-list celebrity in
Canada he's well-known as a director of
movies that don't typically get great
reviews Barry Sherman invested in most
of these films do what you got to do
new trouble from Angela I met Frank for
lunch and he is a colorful guy to say
the least if you want to talk about
unprintable language he certainly uses a
lot of it I just felt it that I ordered
to Barry to give my two cents you know I
don't think I'll ever get over this
incredible tragedy this this senseless
act as long as I live on this planet you
can see the appeal of hanging out with
him for very particularly because he
would have been so dramatically
different from the others who the other
people who who Barry Sherman would have
seen and dealt with on a daily basis
meeting Frank was not uncomfortable at
all he was happy to help he had checked
me out he knew he knew about me I think
I found him on Facebook and sent him a
note asking if he would meet and after a
few days he responded and said that he
would but he did make clear to me he
pulled me close as we were leaving that
first lunch and said you know do the
right thing for my friend and if you
don't I'm gonna come to London and find
you he had been questioned by the police
he is emphatic that he had nothing to do
with with the murder but he is of course
emblematic indicative of the tone of
some of these financial entanglements
and those entanglements are to many
people very suspicious
Hank its Inga the acting inspector of
the homicide squad says the
investigation into who killed Barry and
honey Sherman is still very active I
feel for the family and the friends that
it's it's dragging on it has been a year
as an attempt to reignite an
investigation the Sherman family has
asked me to announce the offer of a
reward of up to ten million dollars for
information leading to the apprehension
and prosecution of those responsible for
the murders honey and Barry Sherman
truth is very strange you know truth is
much stranger than fiction that's why I
love this job is that you keep finding
out that what happens in the real world
is just as weird or weirder than
Hollywood could ever come up with it
seems pretty clear to to all involved
that something that Barry Sherman got
involved in went wrong and and came back
at him if you think about the crime it
is remarkable in many ways one of the
things that's remarkable is that his
wife was killed and the other thing that
I think has confounded a lot of the
investigators is when there are hits
it's usually a bullet it's usually quick
it's done cleanly efficiently in a way
that allows a quick getaway Barry and
honey Sherman were strangled to death so
there's this confusing tangle of
evidence that for the police and and for
anyone else trying to understand this it
doesn't all point in one direction and
that's I think what is so tantalizing
about this is a mystery in some ways and
I think it's a mystery that's going to
endure
[Music]
you